hey everyone I'm Walter burn a Z AK and
this is top five today we're focusing on
Disney's worst of the worst this is the
result of a Twitter poll that I put up
and you guys all had very strong
opinions on the topic Disney's animated
villains are iconic memorable legendary
even scary to us when we were growing up
watching them they set standards that a
lot of film strive for when it comes to
fleshing out their antagonists and
making an all-around quality bad guy it
is safe to say however then that all of
Disney's villains over the years have
been quality bad guys some of them are
pretty bad and not a good bad way a
decent amount of them just don't live up
to the greats across the 56 feature
films the mouse house is created over
the decades there are many of them that
belong in this list but I had to narrow
it down to the most pathetic ones these
are the top 5 worst Disney animated
movie villains number 5 the Horned King
from the Black Cauldron Oh
just in case the Horned King fits in
here amongst Disney's worst villains but
maybe not for the reasons you'd expect
the Horned King is a skeletal preacher
whose main objective is to retrieve the
Black Cauldron and resurrect his army of
the Dead called the cauldron born he
wishes to become a god among mortal men
and everything he does in this film is
in service of that purpose first things
first
I've always disliked the Black Cauldron
when we were kids one of my little
brothers constantly wanted to watch this
and quest for Camelot both of which I
don't exactly consider classics so
admittedly I have a small bias against
this movie to begin with
now the Horned King is definitely
intimidating looking and sounding they
weren't afraid to push the scare factor
with this guy to a certain degree anyway
I don't have a problem with his
appearance or aesthetics
[Music]
the main reason I'm putting him on this
list is because he had so much wasted
potential but that look in John Hurt's
voice the horn king should be sitting
close to the top of the heap in terms of
Disney Villains but instead we get this
[Music]
his cauldron born plan of creating an
army of the Dead is pretty cool and
looks good on screen when it happens but
ultimately the Horned King is a chump
[Music]
what a waste he's barely even in the
film and that doesn't work to his
advantage believe there are much better
hooded skeleton villains out there
number four Madame Medusa from the
rescuers drop the madam and you have a
built-in great villain Madame Medusa is
as mean as they come and has a temper
that matches her fiery red hair
she owns a shady pawn shop in New York
and is hopelessly obsessed with diamonds
particularly the world's biggest a
diamond called the devil's eye its
location is in a cave that she herself
cannot fit into so she kidnaps an orphan
penny to retrieve the devil's eye for
her we've seen this type of villain done
much better by Disney both before and
after the rescuers
I don't think Madame Medusa is a
completely worthless enemy for penny and
the rescuers this scene was actually
pretty cold don't forget that to the
orphanage I'll never get daft it adopted
what makes you think but that's about it
I just can't stand her should that be a
quality a good villain has well not
really sometimes but not in this way
[Applause]
[Music]
ultimately she's forgettable and fades
from my brain pretty quickly after
seeing the movie who was worse you asked
number three see and am from Lady and
the Tramp seeing a more a pair of
identical cats that wreak havoc in
ladies owner's house they are protected
by Aunt Sarah and blamed lady for the
destruction they committed very sneaky
and underhanded these devious felines
are notorious for their deceitful
demeanor and calculated chaos it's that
song man that freakin song I know
they're only in lady in the Tramp for a
very short amount of time but they got
on my nerves extremely quickly
I just hate those damn cats
[Music]
is this my emotions getting the best of
me maybe but every single time I hear
that song I get annoyed to the max it's
always been that way ever since I saw
lady in the Tramp for the first time
I've despised these two and they would
probably be even closer to the top spot
but thankfully they're only on screen
for a couple short minutes number two
Edgar Balthazar from the Aristocats this
is probably Disney's most incompetent
villain
Edgar is the longtime boil butler of the
very wealthy madam bond female when he
overhears that she plans on giving her
fortune to her cats before him after she
passes away
Edgar becomes very frustrated and
frantic to get rid of the cats so he may
directly inherit her money himself he
decides the only proper way to do that
is to abandon them far from their home
and play dumb
when questioned concerning their
whereabouts yeah Edgar's pretty dumb
although Madame bonfá mill is a little
wacky for leaving her fortune to her
cats Edgar would have control of the
money but still that takes crazy cat
lady to a whole different level in any
case Edgar is pretty bad at being a
villain while sometimes it results in a
few funny bits it doesn't excuse how
weak of a bad guy he is the guy is
constantly outwitted by a few cats and a
mouse I almost feel sorry for him came
back now I don't and the number one
worst Disney animated movie villain is
governor Ratcliffe in Pocahontas
Pocahontas is definitely not one of my
favorite Disney movies and governor
Ratcliffe is just one of the reasons why
Ratcliffe is the leader of a voyage to
modern-day Virginia in the early 1600s
while he repeatedly tells his crew this
is the adventure of their lives his true
ambition is to discover gold and hoard
all the glory for himself when he spots
Native American spies in the newly
claimed Jamestown he orders an attack on
them and begins obsessing with killing
the rest nearby this guy sticks out like
a sore thumb when compared to Disney's
great villains when King James he's the
goal of these prisons on earth success
will be mine at last he's so lame I know
that's the point of his character but
he's so over-the-top lame that it comes
at a detriment to him and the movie and
he's in it a lot with multiple subpar
songs to be sung
[Music]
[Applause]
is my not like you and B which means
they must be either every time he popped
up I couldn't wait for him to go away
everything from his voice the character
design is obnoxious Pocahontas in
general I just don't like very much
there are some things I enjoy in it but
let me take a look at what came directly
before it The Lion King Aladdin Beauty
and the Beast The Little Mermaid
this just doesn't come anywhere close to
matching up and it was years before
Disney went on a roll again governor
Ratcliffe should have been a stronger
and more confident character to play off
John Smith who also isn't exactly a well
drawn character but with a more
discernable foe and rival they both
would have benefited and the movie would
have at least been more interesting it's
not like they were sticking to history
anyway
of course these five villains are pretty
much exceptions to mostly great
adversaries our heroes have to deal with
in many of our favorite Disney animated
movies here's to leaving these ones in
the past and continuing to move forward
to new and interesting antagonists I
want to hear what you guys think what is
your least favorite Disney animated
movie villain what do you want me to
cover next in the show leave a comment
and let me know for more content
subscribe to my personal channel
youtube.com slash awesome Walter like
mini Facebook page facebook.com slash
awesome Walter B and follow me on
Twitter to take part in more polls about
what may be covered in the future come
on back next week for a brand new
episode of top 5
[Music]
you